tell me about your your thoughts on this
twilight renaissance on netflix on one
hand you're like oh i'm old my god i
feel like that was five minutes ago
now it's like 10-year anniversary how
will spencer go down as one of the most
impactful roles you've ever done is
there a specific scene
that would add to that making it even
that much more impactful for you
the experience really does become a sort
of quilt memory uh i it's really hard to
isolate days from one another it's funny
to hold an entire life in a
proposed sort of conceptual three-day
period the movie is so far from literal
that it's not like we focus very
finitely on these three days and sort of
we don't look outside of that the whole
thing is kind of a dream
and it's kind of a i don't know like a
reflection of
her inspiration
that she had on steve knight the writer
and pablo and myself kind of all melded
together
so i think oddly i don't know i think
just
the the biggest thing the most
resounding takeaway that i have from
making this movie was
probably
how how big and how small i felt as her
they can't change you have to change
you have to be able to do things you
hate you hate there has to be two of you
it's the real one
and the one they take pictures of it
i've never felt so big and so small at
the same time there are certain
impactful and really
resonant and
you know touching people that exist and
they're sort of lightning in a bottle
one and a million special
but their inner lives sometimes are
maybe not what it feels like for
everyone outside do you know what i mean
it's like this woman was able to reach
out and touch so many people and
responsible for so much good in the
world it's just a not sort of unyielding
unbelievable amount of goodness but at
the same time it's just really nice to
be like you know to fall into
sort of wake of her dreamy nature
was such a trip and i've never done
anything like it oh i have to bring this
up another iconic role obviously
tell me about your your thoughts on this
twilight renaissance on netflix it's
like
all these new fans rediscovering even
olivia rodrigo unironically obsessing
with her own like twilight merch what do
you what do you make of all this like
this resurgence of of twilight i mean it
was so big and now it's so big again
it's awesome
i had no idea this is great
like i saw that it was on netflix and i
was like oh right it's on netflix yeah
yeah i was like it was on there while i
was looking through um dude it's
it's weird because it doesn't feel
it feels incredibly far away and also
still not that far away from me and my
time in this moment i don't know like um
it on one hand you're like oh i'm old my
god actually it was five minutes ago
now it's like 10-year anniversary and i
was like wow i have to go to my high
school anniversary already
say it
family
it's rad i uh
i don't know i haven't really that
hasn't touched me yet i can't wait for
someone like you know who's
12 or 15 to suddenly think like it's
like when you're a little and you tell
your parents how great jimi hendrix is
or something not to say that i'm
remotely comparing twilight to jimi
hendrix but you know what i mean where
they're like dude you don't even know
it's like so sick yeah i do
i was in that
different now
it's been a long time i know i think
it's amazing i i don't know i think i i
i get it i've watched all the harry
potters recently it's fun to just sit
and sort of it's also the holidays it's
cozy it makes sense to me i want to ask
you something now this is i don't know
if you know this but this year marks the
20th anniversary of the panic room so
looking back
what would that that version of you that
younger girl version of you
how would she look at your career now
and what would you say to that younger
version that little girl
oh i think she would be so stoked
yeah i think um
i i wasn't the little kid that
desperately wanted to be like an actress
but i i wanted to make movies so badly i
just never wanted to leave a movie set
it's where i wanted to live i want to
spend all my time there
and that is what i've done i couldn't
have written it better myself i feel
just unbelievable it's just surreal
gratitude for that
um so i would say dude you killed it
and say
um
i don't know every every sort of salve
that i would like attempt to offer i
would actually probably take right back
because you have to go through it man
you have to learn every hard lesson and
like
you know
uh every step that has led me here i
think has been like
messy but the right one and um
no i'm just like
totally over the moon to be here so i
would be like dude you're fine just keep
going
you know you uh i want to talk a little
bit about your fashion choices for
spencer for the press tour they were
awesome
are you prepared for the
you know the the non-in-person fashion
experience so have you mastered your
your zoom wardrobe for awards night if
it's you know let's just say you know
chest that type of thing
oh man yeah uh
well i probably won't be too far off
from this right i mean if you think
about it this is like i was thinking
maybe a shirt of some kind no um i
haven't thought about that
particular aspects that would be gnarly
it's funny you put someone in front of a
bookshelf and suddenly they're in full
hair and makeup and like you know a
whole outfit it just it doesn't fit you
need to go outside or something you know
like take it take it to some environment
that you're like you know suspend
reality for a moment because the reality
of the bookshelf with the full do is
just like
it's really hard to marry those two
things i think you're doing a pretty
good job right now i think i think it's
working pink just a little pop of pink
yeah it kind of ties in with the little
vase in the back you know oh yeah yeah
is that going on same color palette okay
speaking why i'm on the subject of
fashion if i could ask how much thought
have you and dylan been giving to
wedding attire your ensemble anything
you can share with us
um
i think that i would
i think the whole thing is that you're
kind of supposed to be a surprise you
know what i mean i mean i guess
traditionally speaking and in this case
i mean who knows how many
in this case i don't even know
detail-wise i don't know how many
iterations we're gonna follow but i um
i'm gonna wear i know what i'm gonna
wear and i can't tell you the palm
springs film festival is always uh it's
always starting the awards season off so
how does it feel for you
to be recognized for spencer i mean this
has got to be a pretty awesome moment in
time
it is beautiful man it is i first of all
i'm in palm springs right now so no one
else showed up
um so i'm here completely ready to talk
about this but i will say that the
sculpture itself is like stunning
if i could if i could just like swing a
move like this i'd start winning a lot
more awards let me just say that
um i loved making this movie so much
mommy
family are all gathered in the drawing
room
they are waiting
[Music]
three days that's it
so many associations that we have with
her are
sad because of how much we
love her i mean i think that the things
that really resonate with me are
actually the more joyful
times that we had making this movie i
was it was so joy-packed
and that is the shadow that she left
behind and um
yeah i just to step into that light is
is something that i have never even come
close to and i had the best time doing
it and everyone that helped make the
movie was
i mean everyone was just so
completely connected and genuinely
curious and and willing to
follow pablo's kind of wild and unique
vision and that's
the most you could ever hope for trying
to put a movie together it was just so
much fun and i loved her so much now
with this honor you are in some
some wild amazing company here julia
roberts amy adams and now now i the list
goes on but all these people kind of
you know went on and were honored and
and got the academy award have you
thought
have you thought of having the prefix on
your name academy award winner academy
award nominee kristen stewart have you
ever has that something you think about
or just blows past you
every one of those syllables just how
long it takes to
just just how long your credit is
um
specifically
no but thank you for bringing that up
that is something to consider um
i
i can't even imagine it to be honest
it's like the coolest
i mean this is tippy top which you go
for you want to connect to the most
people you possibly can through doing a
movie that's why we make them
um so i
i yeah but i also just have never really
i don't know i've never functioned in
this
realm of like i just don't think i'm an
oscar person i don't know like i've just
been working for so long and i i like
love
what i do and and the i i don't know
it's just what a stunning like
completely um kind of surreal
opportunity
to do something like that that feels so
true to you and so of a moment
and reflective of something that
inspires you in history and then just
sort of blast it out so universally and
then talk about i don't know i think
like
the whole oscar thing is um i don't know
it makes it makes people giddy and it's
always the question
and i completely understand why because
it is it is such a cool thing to share
something you love with that many people
um it's been already it's been like such
a wild ride all right now i want to open
the floor i want to give you the uh the
moment to thank whoever you like for for
this recognition and uh just speak
really and it's all yours well
i would like to thank the palm springs
film festival for existing at all and
loving movies the way we all do
and
um
every single person that was involved in
putting this thing together came from
the most beautiful and open place and i
think that that just trickles right down
from the top because this is a movie
about princess diana
i think the only reason we made this
movie is because we love her and um
it also it came from her and writes a
pablo who is kind of the only person i
really feel like singling out right now
other than the entire effort that it
took to make the whole thing we were all
here for him and her and um
yeah how cool that we get to sort of
like traipse off with this movie and
watch the life that it can have because
it's like bigger than i ever imagined so
thank you
from the bottom of my heart genuinely
[Music]